okay
um I think this is good
for this group
too this is our like middle
group
um the question is like how do you
decide what you're going to work
on and how to not be technique
Centric we're not technique Centric
um so what's always behind everything is
the single goal of the
training okay and then what you're
trying to do is move them there and
technique is not the single goal of the
training it is that for many people
because they're moderns they're
materialists they're
ferites so they're
superficial they stick to the VIS
ible uh and the tangible and they ignore
the infinite the
intangible the Divine you see so they
just you just pick techniques and you do
techniques
uh this is why you have that myth that's
so prevalent in that
population that the techniques are
self-defense so even though they say and
Christopher H noted this and I've always
agreed with this
position even though you push an iido
person just
enough they will tell you it's not about
any kind of Marshal
practicality but you push a little
harder and then they will always tell
you how the techniques can be used
martially okay uh it doesn't matter who
they are doesn't matter what kind of
hippie uh pacifist pseudo
pacifist uh you know
how woke they are it doesn't
matter um their ethics is exactly the
same as a eye for eye kind of stuff
okay you just have to push hard enough
and then okay now I'm going to throw you
and then that's why you have the myth
because they have to be nonviolent and
they're they're superficial not thought
through Paradigm that when they do throw
you it's in a way that's not going to
hurt you which again is a bunch of
okay uh it's nonfunctioning
across the board it's
delusional Etc but they work on
techniques and if you push like what are
you where are you going with this
technique they can't say it's something
as stupid as I'm trying to get the next
rank you see because everyone knows if
you push just a little bit on that
there's not much meaning in that like
and then what do you do oh I get the
next Rank and then what do you do you
know there it goes nowhere so they have
to go well I'm learning how to defend
myself if I need to you know they get
something like that going um but all it
does is justify that you're technique
Centric goes nowhere and you create this
delusion that it is going somewhere with
some fabricated utility okay but that is
not our goal so we don't design a
class uh on the technique the the the
art itself which they Define as
technique um is not what's at the center
of this what is at the center is the
singular goal and then the individual
Desi proximity to that goal and that's
what the teacher is there for so to get
you more proximal to the singular
goal for that reason uh the Sensei Desi
relationship is extremely
pivotal um in so many ways that for most
moderns they just can't do it I I would
say as as deep as you got into
modernity uh you're cow you're a coward
that's what it is you you you've been
taken by the darkness the fear has you
Warriors call that person a coward so I
call that you're a
coward you can't commit to the
training uh you can't self- displace all
those things are terrifying to you so
you
dabble and that is why a very dabbling
level technique is
uplifted it's the the uh the patients
are running the hospital so to speak
okay so you have a bunch of people who
are too filled with fear to move Beyond
technique making technique the pen
ultimate okay um towards the
significance of the Sensei Desi
relationship um it's like a marriage
contract because marriage is a spiritual
contract
and like a modern-day marriage like we
think of it the master disciple
relationship is one of
commitment both
ways
so just like in in my marriage I got to
suck up a lot of uh in order to
maintain the
relationship um according to the ideals
of the relationship and that happens in
the Sensei Desi relationship too you got
to suck up a lot of stuff uh as you help
someone move from where they are
proximal to the singular goal okay and
that's why I don't let the people on the
patreon group call me sensei
because I'm I have not entered into a
contract with you because you are not
committed to me uh you still follow your
Shihan you still do your
ferite uh community activities you quote
this Japanese person and that Japanese
person all of it is contradictory to
what I say but you don't see it yet
because you were at a superficial
training so you just call me Dave and I
I don't owe you anything um and what you
do receive from me like uh the beginner
or the less committed dasing is just my
own practice so my own practice of how I
relate to that singular goal is uh
through Karma Yoga so that is why I give
away what I give away uh but it has
nothing to do with you from your point
of view you don't deserve it you can't
do anything with it uh and there's no
point doing
superficial courtesies of calling me
Sensei you could call me Dave you could
call me it's the same to me
okay so when we're in this middle group
we are looking at the relationship
hasn't yet fostered as fully as it needs
to and
so what you're going to work on is not
going to be what I work on when when I'm
up up here okay so a simple
example um on my
sons uh we if if it's just us or they're
here um predominantly here they're the
majority we tend to do more fighting
stuff um
because I am doing full Pudo at their
level so what I mean by that is that
we're going to use violence against the
self to see if you can keep the self
released okay that is budo that is what
it's doing um at the lower levels as we
move down we're not going to do
techniques we're going to work on
bringing them towards that singular goal
of release a self okay um we take
advantage of all three components but
usually we have to hang out at the the
physical level at the lower level we
have to hang out at the physical
component level or or we can start to
move up towards the energetic level okay
depends on the person um so down down
here for
example
uh I want them to be strong this I let
the four disciplines uh Rock so it is
not good for example for our adolescent
males to not have muscle mass and to not
have um a decent amount of male hormones
rocking in their body because that
without that they will tend to be
vulnerable to mood disorders which are
expressions of self-attachment and so
there's no point in trying to talk about
communion with God when your body your
your your hormon horal system is
you over okay so hey see if you could
just show up and uh get rid of your boy
boobs and start getting some pecs and
actually have some some muscle tone to
your body uh and that seems like well
that's a lot no it's not it's not for a
teenage boy that that body is so ripe
and Prime for conditioning um to tell
you the truth truth as a uh 50 I think
I'm 58 now it's a 58y old man I'm like
Okay because that dude can
just live for like a couple months and
his body has radically changed but not
everyone can do it because it's
difficult to be regiment like that when
the world is pulling you so you always
have a reason to not do the lifting you
see I had I'm doing this I'm doing that
um you know for so for example this is
why I say the four disciplines work at
subtle levels um you're playing games
all night long and now you don't sleep
because your sleep hygiene blows and now
you can't get up the next day and go
change your body than got it so you know
what you'll hang out there you let you
hang out there and we're lifting today
when when you show up okay that's enough
that's where that person is at um for
example Tristan was here the other
day and um he so he's in that same group
but again the dude like he always walks
around with his shirt off at home and
looks like a a cartoon he looks
like a comic book dude um even
his brother who's who's uh older now but
ronan's in he's ining his 20s and you
guys might remember Andrew they bought
you're like oh I don't know what's
happening you're getting older is what's
happening and so uh you know Ronin is
fit but Tristan's calling him fat
okay so Tristan is walking around with
his shirt off constantly he looks like a
comic book
um but so he's good on muscle tone but I
want his V2 Max higher and so we did a
hit workout that day right and he got
nauseous from it cuz the oxygen debt
right so we're training um each person
for where they're at we don't have a
curriculum that the person is forced to
fit okay um so the hence there's no way
we're going to do techniques because
some overarching uh Federation is
telling you you have to do these
techniques see we're going to work at
the individual ual level in a very
personal and intimate relationship
between the Sensei and the teacher which
is governed by how much commitment do
you have just like any relationship
right you have some wife you don't
have much intimacy there's just no way
around it okay uh so we're working that
way okay
um what is that singular goal I already
stated it it's the skill of the release
of self okay but I'm going to ask this
group here um CU these are the people in
a marriage with me uh to what end is
that speak up so the camera can pick you
up what is what do we do with the skill
of the release of
sell go ahead I would
Sayan us everywhere from what we eat to
when we go to bed too late to when
letting work get to us and we realize
that we're coming to class and prepared
okay um yes it's it's in everything but
to what end is what I asked what do you
got to do more to tolerate more to
approach communion with the Divine okay
so those to me are contradictory
statements to do more do you see and
then communion with the Divine and and
this is very common because we're in
that group
okay we're we're not quite getting
everything so this is like the the
people that are um practicing uh
spiritual Traditions today because they
can't dare be religious do you see there
I'm not religious I'm spiritual because
they're secular materialists
without realizing it you see and why
can't they be religious because they're
filled with fear you got it like no no
no I would have to lose control of my of
who and what I am so when I'm spiritual
I'm not in a cult you you get that kind
of idea um Ivan shared with me a podcast
recently and it's to uh Zen abbots one
of the Chan tradition one of the Zen
tradition and uh the Chan Abbot is
making a great Point um it's very
similar to how I say you can't it's not
a salad bar the dojo is not a
salad bar you can't pick and choose what
you want to do uh it doesn't function
that way and uh the Chan Abbot is
pointing out how today um in the past
you used to have to go to the temple and
actually engage in the practice with the
teacher you see but now everything is
online so you have a bunch of Buddhist
here in air quotes which by which we
mean not Buddhist um just like ioka in
air quotes by which we not
aikidoka uh what they do is they pick
and choose what they like do you see
okay but what are they picking and
choosing uh by what do they like they
like what reifies the ego you see and so
it's just feeding the ego it's not
dismantling the ego okay and what they
pick and choose then that reifies the
ego is all those things that modern
world tells you you're you're doing here
so it's going to help me at work it's
going to help me find peace it's going
to help my blood pressure you get all
that and we want it to do something and
that is not what we are doing here
Divine communion is not uh uh having it
do something for us okay if you keep
that mind if you keep that position in
your head you will never release the
self you will keep trying to do
something by releasing the self and when
you keep trying to do something your ego
tripartite mind keeps functioning that
is a reification of self that is an
obstacle to Divine Grace so you are
contesting God okay and so we're not
doing that so the answer is there what
are we trying to do with the skill of
release practice non-c contestation
towards God it's a concentric
art so we have non- contestation between
Yin and yangong at the energetic
component non- contestation with UK at
the Marshall uh physical component and
this is non-c contestation at the
spiritual component okay that is the
singular goal so what we end up doing is
nothing more than uh
problematizing um self-attachment self-
reification at those three component
levels that that is all we're doing we
don't do techniques we use a technique
as it reveals that what we're working on
but we're not here to learn techniques
okay uh and very quickly you know we
learned the hard way so you're going to
do some technique right yeah I got my
technique and then sooner or later we're
doing G Wasa and you're like do
you get it because you were doing
techniques and you were not doing self-
relase
okay um as an example
today what I do sometimes is
is sometimes there's a positive lesson
for a person that's on the mat because
the
degree of population the variance in the
population is just too
dispersed and I can't come up with one
way uh that everyone is positively
addressing self- reification
okay uh and so what I do then is I have
a positive less for that one to two to
three people and then I have a negative
lesson uh for the remaining people and
what I mean by this somebody is very
close to getting to another level of
self-release uh and other people like
you're just you can't do it you're we're
we're working Beyond you so for example
uh yesterday's technique on on vouching
your question yesterday like I can't get
the neck hand to function because
there's no I key yet there it was the
same question when we did um the knife
the knife training with Andrew and Ronin
you had to seize the center to create
the Dilemma seizing of the center is
from the ik adhesion okay and when we
allowed the UK to counter our angles of
deflection if we did not have their
Center they were just going to have a
field day with us but if we had their
Center to counter our angles of
deflection they would have to first free
their Center you see and that created
the Dilemma so we reached the limits of
your uh skill set with ie not there on
the ninth day and we reach the limits of
the um technique in adaga at the IE
adhesion Point okay as well so it's a
kind of negative uh lesson for you
you're not going to learn it in those
drill in that technique and those drills
we were doing uh even yesterday I said
you not going to learn I in Minag you
have to go back to the IE development
set okay uh the reason being is the
technique assumes the presence of the
skill it's too uh complex a drill um and
there's too much stress to generate the
adaptation in any kind of reliable way
okay uh so we go to the other drills
where things are Made Simple uh not
complex and the stress is hugely reduced
okay but it still motivates you to go
I actually need to get this do
you see and that's a negative lesson you
see because you see other people doing
it you feel other people doing it and it
helps you get to let me really
concentrate on this do you see and you
start probing for what are you feeling
what and not only what your Naga is
doing but what you feel and when you're
doged you see and so it's maybe it's not
going to produce the resultant but it
gets the soil primed for the result to
uh arise okay um so what we're working
on today and to be forthright we're
we're working on Virginia and everyone
else is going to get a negative lesson
okay because Virginia is very freaking
close to getting
over this obstacle that you've been on
you go you sometimes you're over
sometimes you're back here and sometimes
you're back here and sometimes you're
over here what what is it it's it's the
uh yanging you you want to Yong Yong
Clash like this is this is the ego
tripartite mind wants to Y Yong Clash so
you always want a Yong Clash uh but it's
made more Yong Yong clashing is already
the darkness the Demonic the
contestation at the spiritual level you
see but it's made more ludicrous for how
much how tall are you 52 and 3 what five
52 and 34 okay and how much do you weigh
136 okay so if made more ludicrous than
136b 52 and 3/4 woman is going to Yong
Yong Clash do you get it it's just like
well that's crazy it's always crazy
whever it is in life um you're pushing
hard at work
right and you're driving yourself nuts
that's crazy too but this is crazy at a
physical component like this is not
going to be it right okay got it so more
reason to get it you're right there it
goes back and forth now if I were to ask
you why does it go back and forth
Virginia what use all the instruction
that you've had so far why is it that
sometimes you get it and then sometimes
you don't what do you think because
I'm functioning from aotus okay true but
what what do you think happens when the
times like you don't get it because it's
not luck do you guys understand that
it's not
luck what do you know from your teaching
the teachings you receive
I'm pushing back I know that okay well
open it up a little higher up on the on
the ranking for what is it so her skill
at the four disciplines relative to the
stress that she's under or putting her
over or under that releasing ability
make makes sense okay so you sleep
crappy you eat crappy you work out
crappy and I would say a lot for you is
the world view the world view is really
the king of the four disciplines the
hardest one to get um but if you pay
attention usually that falters first and
then you falter in the other three okay
but the the king of the four disciplines
the world view is so subtle that we
don't really notice it but it does have
huge impacts on this okay so I would go
back in my mind I see who's here and
then I see you here and I go okay what
are we going to work on today we know
where we're going we know what we're
working on is the skill of self-release
okay H so that we're no longer
contesting God that is the only goal
um and I remember we were doing the co
you set the other days and there were a
lot of those drills I've seen you rock
before but you were unable to do them
that day remember they were like the
walking drill uh was it four and five
was really jacking you up okay so we're
going to uh spent some time on on
Virginia to get her uh off of that okay
so she's young young clashing why are we
young young clashing we want a result
okay we want the person to go away move
away not overpower us okay and what I'm
going to do is come in through her body
and show her that you you're going to
achieve that but not by those means
okay so we're working with the
following um let's say we have UK coming
this
way and we don't want to I'm going to
task you with
something I don't want to be moved okay
this is a stress
adaptation uh device for training so for
example as I already mentioned for my
sons uh we're going to practice fighting
because violence is more likely than
anything else to trigger you and see if
you exhibit U behaviors or actions or
reactions consistent with self-
reification or whether you stay in the
godm state or not physically
energetically and spiritually okay this
is no different it's just
simplified so you UK is going this way
and your task with not moving you see it
sets up the potential for a young young
clash and we're going to increase that
potential by saying not only do you not
move but they have to
move you see and so it's setting up now
will you Yong Yong clash with the
obvious materialist way or will you use
your internals so that this energy is
actually not contesting energetically
with either of these goals do not move
and make them go the other way
okay um for some of us as I said you're
going to do this stuff and okay cool but
sooner or later someone in the class is
going to do it right on you and you're
going to get the negative lesson I'm not
doing that okay all right so that's
that's what we're doing with our little
exercise you can see how it's just a
stress adaptation model it sets you up
for self- reification and
contestation and then to do the drill
correctly you have to do not that okay
so what I'm trying to teach Virginia now
and anybody else who gets it is going to
learn it CU it's
Universal
um if the contact point is here at the
hands
or let's say let's use the center the
center of gravity of UK okay is there
and I am creating a Coq projection
Vector through the
center the more Yang that is coming in
so if we have y plus here the greater
the projection going out okay because
that energy gets internalized and gets
rebounded off the ground and boom it'll
bounce out
okay just like the pool analogy I gave
yesterday okay the deeper you bring that
ball under the water the higher it goes
up the less you bring it in it only goes
up a little okay all right there are
ways of increasing the yangong value at
the contact point at the projection
point
other than pushing right into
it because and we want to learn those
ways because when I push right into it
that kind
of uh is very close to just pushing do
you see that okay so what we're going to
do instead is we're going to work
from and we're going to learn this is
coku we're going to learn how to use the
iy
hand
at you see the X
there the same 90 fluctuation that we
always do in iido so we're going to use
the iy
hand to move to spiral
rotate so it it looks like it's here two
dimensionally static but it's going to
keep moving So eventually it goes here
here gone it and when we do that we're
actually
sucking UK in more we're adding more
Yong to the contact point and without
pushing
them we load the contact point for the
projection okay to do
this at Virginia's level and and
everyone else here is you cannot focus
Fus on the C line at the loss of the iy
line okay because when you
do you're going to have to push
okay this Focus between the the either
or the CQ line or the iy line is your
dichotomous mind functioning you can
only do one thing at a time you can only
do one hand at a time and those hands
have to do the same thing okay all that
is
the uh ego tripartite mind functioning
okay so what we have to do is this hand
the koku hand has to be alive the iy
hand has to be equally alive they don't
do the same thing but they're
complimenting each other okay so there's
not two yongs and there's not two
Yin what is common is this hand
disappears I just don't use it anymore
and I just push on the center or
uh this hand will not fluctuate at the
90 it to pushes on the center you have
two pushing hands okay or as Bing is
getting there it goes on and off boom
gone it's a little more it's a little
more and that is that vine fluctuating
back and forth
dichotomously okay where I want to go
from there is where I make this a
negative lesson for even Virginia to see
if we get there okay so I'll show you
what that drill looks like
now okay in essence it's C hole but
we're standing as we're going to work on
our uh midfoot ground vect and also as
you can see how tailor is she has a HT
knee and so she's not she we
I'm not going to make her do s w we're
going to do standing okay so it's very
tailored to where she's
at the ferite will go W you got to do uh
you got to do CAD DOA it's got to be
sitting down that's technique Centric
well I don't give a if she never
kneels again okay it doesn't matter I
don't care whether she never stands or
not because that has nothing to do with
Divine communion okay so in this girl we
start out with the wrist grab and I'm
going to here's the C youan is already
on her Center you see but I'm going to
use this hand with an adhesion to keep
loading this
hand and the Y value is increasing you
feel it a young value
increases and you'll get the same
projection without your hands pushing
okay so normally at at the lower levels
right where do we do I I want you just
to do that we're at at her
level and I'm not going to push this the
C you hand I'm going to use the I hand
to load the C hand
okay so here we
go there it's pushing out you see but it
never pushes out it keeps loading this
hand keeps loading this hand keeps
loading this hand just pushing out just
pushing out keep
loading there you
go keep it on keep it on it goes off
don't smell the the projection this is a
goal oriented don't smell it keep it
keep the
relationship need some off it's a little
hard right it's a little heavy for you
take it off good keep it going don't
push out
you're going like
this you're going like this and pay
attention how much projection is there
actually on this
hand not much do you
see it again don't get confused it
doesn't have to be that angle I just
have to keep feeding it so I won't go
down into it but you can feel that it
increases the the pressure there okay
but it's going to do the same thing
there you see I'm going out it's doing
the same
thing okay all right so we'll work on it
try so how am I
stand regular yeah just regular
okay
now I just
and my drill is what Virginia what am I
trying to steal for to load the Yang
hand yeah I load the Yang hand with the
IT hand okay that's what I want to do
see that this is pretty light you get it
okay got
heavier there it is
Boom Boom
I want you to feel how that handle start
to increase y value throughout the
movement of this never goes out you're
going to KN go out
and my stance is
irrelevant Dan is irrelevant because
why because it's not in the stance it's
so what what is it
it's in the
vector it's in you rebounding um from
the earth so here's what I'm going to
tell you stance is 2
feet and when I don't stand in any
stance I don't have a twoot relationship
anyone anytime someone says a stance
they're going to name the relationship
between two
feet you're doing a cat it's a
relationship between the two feet it's a
relationship between the two feet even
even though on one leg even though
predominantly on one leg it's still a
relationship between two feet we don't
want a relationship between two feet
okay all I need is a single round Vector
so they St as irrelevant because doesn't
matter what the relationship is between
my two Fe okay martially that's
important more your Marshal base is
dependent upon the relationship between
two Fe the less Dynamic you can be okay
and uh hopefully we get there at the end
and I'll show you what what I mean by
that okay but you have to be able to be
dynamic you cannot be like you see those
ta Chi Masters who are going to they're
going to you're going to fight freaking
mik Tyson who's moving all over and
you're like here like this you see that
cuz you're going to go you're going to
touch them and then you're going to go
no you're not you're going to touch them
they're going to deviate and then
they're going to CL walk you over the
top which is what we see every single
time okay so careful on the stances try
it again
[Music]
okay so where do you feel her her
uh let's call it the the uh radius of
her CQ do you do you can you deduce what
I mean by that it's going over the
shoulder okay you feel that going over
the shoulder is it is it actually going
over your shoulder I know this Vector is
over your shoulder but is the radius is
it actually going over your
shoulder in other words is is your
shoulder going flying backwards right
now so no so what's the where's the
radius you feel it in your chest where
do you feel it it's kind of going into
the space right is that where you feel
it think about it
so I feel here but I think that's my own
tension okay so just release that
tension where is the radius of
her
CQ anyone else take a guess where do you
see
it do it again same exact thing don't
change anything where do you see
it here uh let's try it again
here so the radius in your shoulder you
see the radius is in your shoulder
shoulder got you see that the vector
might be in your shoulder but the radius
is not do you guys get that okay so
again I'm down here the vector might be
in your chest but the radius is not in
your chest you see yes you guys
understand
okay yes or no yeah okay so I want you
to
understand see it from the first example
the shoulder it in the chest you
see the
radius here is we know in iido we're
going to we're going to spiral rotate
not
only across the three components okay
so the Tom Den for example is going to
SP rotation okay but at the physical
level the relationship between knock nag
huk is also going to spir locate
okay so that is
why we don't do yesterday's technique
like
this the fight did not did not TR rotate
we we are going to have the whole thing
turn how far at least
90 okay so we throw it over here the
two people UK and net for an attacker
and the defender the defender is going
to follow rotate okay so that is why we
can talk about a
radius got it and the radius is
when you have a
circle the radius is the distance from
this the circumference to the center
okay so I was asking how long is the
radius or where is this end of the
radius okay
or uh how big is her Circle
so we'll just do with one hand okay
and from the
grip I'm more about
there if the radius was actually past
that like this you see then the shoulder
gets
display I would not
see this
see can so can you push
in no but I'm hanging out in front of
you you see yes you get that so my
radius is not yet in that center it's
kind of relaxed it's kind of
here and as a result I just tilt you
can you see
yes but I have to compress you feel that
you see and I'm compressing and you can
look at the difference watch his watch
his
body feel your Center like what do you
feel in your Center it should probably
feel pretty relaxed yeah you're tilted
but it feels pretty
relaxed
boom right and you can see how he
already looks like he's like that you
see cuz I'm pushing into that
Center uh and not you see there I'm
pushing into the center got it and now I
do I keep that line and now I do this
thing so let's look at what he's doing
here on the first one he's going to
tilt until he can't tilt it anymore he
loses
balance on this one into the body he's
already moving that foot you see that
because this now is loading his hand so
go back to the lesson that we're working
on okay feel whatever pressure that is
but it's here it's not here it's here
okay and now I start to load that and
you can see what his body wants to do it
wants to move this foot you see
okay not line of gravity
outside until he moves the foot on his
own to protect himself from falling okay
there's a difference there all right try
it keep going
that's
good good all
right okay so again at this level so
what I've done as a teacher already uh
is they all know the techniques you got
to you do have to introduce the the the
clay that you're going to model with
okay so they know the
techniques um their problem is
not which is the teacher's problem is
not learning more techniques okay this
is how to actually do the techniques so
that is why uh on this group we are
going to work on this stuff okay again
there's a lot of people in the community
I uh I'm really talking about those
that and as Ian knows I'm an and
these people these people know it too
okay but your teacher has to be an
um you're you're doing it wrong you're
trying to
take some things from here and then
you're going to go back to your fedorite
Ps and you're going to try to be a big
fish there um and this kind of posits as
I was talking to Karen about this posits
the delusion that the two are um able to
be brought together when in fact they're
antithetical to each other uh if we go
back to um
Virginia's uh realization that she can
and cannot and depending upon the four
disciplines and in particular the rule
view uh all the teacher prescribed those
disciplines and so you're just not
committed to your teacher's way it is
traditionally how we look at it okay uh
which is how those two abbots are
talking about things okay what are we
doing instead is we're picking and
choosing which part of the teachings we
want but we're always going to pick and
choose according to the ego reification
process we're not going to pick the
things that are uncomfortable or you
know we're always going to pick uh the
self that's what's happening so they're
antithetical so um Karen this hence my
email reply to you on on uh you made the
right choice and I I have people right
underneath me who still can't make that
choice uh but that's just part of the
marriage between me and them okay so
here we're working with this level they
know all the techniques but they don't
have the internals yet so we're doing
the internal uh my sons are not here so
we're not fighting we're not doing
violence stuff uh you know just as a
side note that I would watch that Emi
from Tristan yesterday holy uh man
that is this incredible ukemi which is
like there's no fear in him and he is so
off balance uh and able not to crash and
hit his head and keep his Center engaged
uh we don't we don't have to do that
what do we have to do today we have to
get this internal stuff going okay so
that's what we're working on so
Virginia's had some time with different
ukas um what I do a lot is I try to
trigger her instinct to Yong Yong so
I'll choose her partners for her I let
her try to pick but as I've done many
times hey switch uh cuz I'm still
working on this so she ended up going
with Sean and with Andrew and I didn't
have to say
because they're bigger people and
they'll trigger the self attachment
response of young young Clash okay so
she's gone for a while that last one
looked pretty good with Andrew so now
I'm going to get in there I'm a little
more sensitive than Andrew uh and I'll
feel what I feel and I'll try to get her
to become aware of what she's doing so
I'm not going to with her uh we
just continue to work on what's going
on good good here catch and I kind of
pick one thing so really I want the iy
hand to stay alive
okay a little off there at the
end keep it
on on it projected so it projected at
the same C you line don't project go go
go go go go go go go go good and I'm
using things to get keep her mind on
that
arm good good
good okay that last one you're in my
center and that's where I want you to be
I want you to feel my
weight just on you're you're kind of a
little high being in my body
here's what I mean you're up here you
see okay I want to be down which has
nothing to do with my hand High you see
okay now I and reason we go high is cuz
there's too much weight in the center
that we stay up in the shoulders I want
to be in your there okay how do I get
there what do you think what do I have
to do and here I am in the shoulders
watch I'm will move my hands
you see there's not much movement in the
CL how do I get there the ches S how
what what stops the chi from
sinking what stops the chi from sinking
tension and what causes tension self you
see I want you to be more down
I want you to feel the
weight and how do I get down there
release More
release okay good here we go back to sh
go C's into the center C's and then
curve there you
go C's
curve that's
it
curve yes good cuz you you were going to
go straight and then you fixed it okay
that's a sign of change
self-correction good
one's straight one's curved
good so now what I do is I always try to
make sure they're understanding the
theory so that they can start
discovering it on their own in other
places uh which is possible because we
have a cohesive understanding of the AR
that's is why it makes sense this is why
people try to steal all the terminology
and phrases understanding them okay um
so if we take kosa which I told you what
we were doing with
kosa in kosa other than in the ferite
way where you do this kind of stuff and
you have two young hands is what you
have okay we don't do that because
there's an energetic component and the
whole point of everything is to lose the
dichotomy and so we don't we would never
have young of anything there has to be a
Yin in there okay and so the yin hand is
on this hand and if you pay attention it
will be
adhering not
projecting and it will be yielding not
going forward and it will be on a
curve the other hand is
doing the CW hand
the poku hand is
projecting it is moving
forward and it is on a
line so this goes this
way this
way see
okay
curve line
curve doesn't matter what you do with
your hand what you
always doing
that not
two don't want you at two
anym okay one's curving and adhering and
that curve and adhering is but is
feeding the projection line okay
try okay so I had a I had where I wanted
to go uh I said I was going to do
something um because I I know where
she's at and I was going to do something
that made it possible for her to do that
because that
um uh is your what is that that is
your you you become attached to the to
the
rooting but I don't root you know what I
mean you guys understand so uh
why why did I teach you rooting at
first okay you know come on you can't do
what no why is it it is a beginner
progression okay what is what is rooting
is where I hold my feet still you see
and I do the projection I was telling
Sean don't move your feet till after
they're projected got it okay so he's
still not
rooting why did I want you to root is
another way of asking the same question
what are you doing when you're moving
your feet you're not feeling the ground
path okay yeah so I don't have a ground
path and what are you using
instead yeah your body momentum you see
which is an external Force engine okay
so you have to you teach people don't
move your feet so that they're not doing
this okay don't move your feet but now
the downside of that is we now are not
able to ground vector internalize
rebound uh dynamically which is why you
have a lot of taichi people that don't
move their feet versus ronin's able to
dance around you see we can dance around
okay right cuz we need to dance around
uh in some situations I can't stand here
and have someone as you saw with the
knife drill I cannot stand still on
someone who's Dynamic I'm dead I have to
be able to move movement becomes more
important but we cannot contrast
movement with the
rebounding you see do you get that so we
start with a progression that makes
distinct body momentum but now we got
stuck okay so when I was going with Sean
you could tell that I'm just walking
around and do being able to do the same
thing okay I wanted us to get there but
we're out of time we have another class
so I I chalk it up and as I watch your
last
rep uh I can see
your materialist ways of understanding
what you were feeling and you got lower
you see you're down here at the
end that came after I told you get into
their Center and even though I told you
it has nothing to do with the height of
your hands it has to do with the release
of self and the sinking of chi and it
just happens you're like no it has to
happen physically you see and so I keep
that in mind as a teacher uh but it
should be expected because that's what
we do as modern materialists and now we
have to work on that which had we had
time we would have worked on that okay
uh the other thing I do is I always ask
people uh at this point do you have any
questions or comments okay right and so
they will come up with everything uh I
usually have to restrict it though to
what we worked on uh and so anything any
questions or comments on what we worked
on yes Andre s say you pointing out that
I have a lot of tension and feeling a
lot of that tension getting caught in
the shoulder and not being able to
figure out how to release that yeah and
specifically it felt like to me
when I put myself in a position or my UK
puts themselves in a position where I'm
getting more downward force on the
projecting
hand okay that's where I really felt
stuck um so I would go back the tension
is a fear response the fear response is
a manifestation of self so we have to
reconcile the fear response okay now if
you pay attention
uh you probably have a lot of
fear right out off the mat do you get it
like oh no this is going to happen oh no
um and this is that that cannot be uh
addressed on the mat it just can't it's
the the
environment is
too um especially if we go up in
training like yesterday cuz yesterday I
told you to you had too much tension on
the throat right and it was too close
for your body mind to human be human
violence do you see especially as you
were training with uh with h Tristan who
never gives a about the hook right
every once in a while I get him too but
he's young and then Taylor it really
it's just what does Taylor feel like
doing that day right isn't that isn't
that honest right some days
he don't give a about you and
you're probably the only one that
modulates on a regular basis is is ronin
wouldn't you guys say right so yesterday
I came started the class kind of decent
and then B by the end he's all like I
got to actually try this cuz I'm not
getting it and Maya's flying
through the air okay ring it's
terrifying and and even Tristan uh
had to bail out of the technique because
that's a whole other level okay so it
was enough human be human violence when
you're training with these people to
trigger the tension response which is a
fear response do you see that and
there's no way uh you're going to be
able to get a handle on that in that
situation it's better to get a handle uh
on it elsewhere on on the mat so off the
mat so you practice uh acts of
acceptance acts of courage courage uh
acts of not retreating right but most
importantly all of those things really
stem from an act of acceptance a sense
that it's going to be okay I'm going to
be okay right and this goes back to the
world view it's going to be okay right
it's going to be okay what is that that
is Faith so in your acts of faith you
can start to build up more courage
because faith is an act of courage
and better to do acts of faith outside
of human be human violence okay uh never
forget that Futo training is
taking uh religious prescriptions and
putting them in an amplified field for
effect which means everything that we
are doing is harder to do here okay so I
would tell you hey get some acts of
faith going outside and off the m and
that's how you would address that okay
because there's no real reason why as I
joked with you on the last
exchange um that a 52 and 3/4 in woman
should trigger you okay but it was you C
all tense from her coming in because
it's it's psycho emotional it's not
actual
reality okay uh did that answer your
question so your acts of faith okay acts
of faith acts of courage and I would
like for you to understand that as no
signs no Acts or behaviors of retreating
acts of
acceptance
right Lou observing that um I felt like
I was not getting the season of Center
but kind of like this felt a little
closer oh it's off because I took it off
or because took their Center out yeah
and it's kind of interesting to go okay
how do I get it back can I get it back
is that and it's like and I'm keeping
the frustration that b and going it's
fine that I'm not getting it right now
yes cuz that that is exactly the same
thing right and you you have and
everyone cuz we have a community and we
all share right and we've had many
conversations after class where you got
down on yourself right for not getting
it and this is how we're working through
that because that getting down on
yourself is the self
reification um and I'm saying yes yes to
everything you're saying because I could
see you doing that and now I'll point
out to you that not too long ago
probably a matter of months only you
couldn't even stay still right do you do
you guys remember that now now I'm just
asking you is actually penetrate the
center a little more which is going to
stress your ability to stay still okay
which is am I staying still because of
an external engine or am I going to
learn how to stay still by releasing the
cheese sinks the ego trip partti mind
drops and they just bounce off okay so
that's where we're going so even though
it was a negative lesson there was stuff
for you with the radius you see aimed at
where you're at to get you to another
level of self release
okay
um now and then I always go okay any
questions off
topic any comments or anything off
topic cool and then we're done okay so
that that's how I organize all the
classes um someone always benefits from
everything maybe not in the same way and
not directly uh we
never we only
film the
um not all but usually close to all the
instructional part uh we don't film all
the coaching and there's all coaching in
between uh the the training okay so this
class is I don't know if this is an hour
and a half two hour class and the video
is not hour and a half two hours you're
only seeing the demonstration part uh
but there's a lot of coaching going on
that's not captured on